[Music]
thank you
now that was some fantastic chow mein
and before you say that sounded racist
you can ask the waiter how'd they say it
having to explain yourself this much to
prove you're not a racist I'm also
having a family dinner at Panda Express
sometimes I look at the background of a
scene and just glaze over for a few
seconds which is what I was doing while
looking at these slip-on shoes which are
suddenly obscured by the appearance of a
footstool bar that wasn't animated in
the previous frames the kids seemed
disappointed that Rick won't play along
with teasing Jerry but how would Rick
having robot arms extend from his body
not be something interesting for the
kids of tick tock to enjoy film that
[ __ ] get those views views are all that
matters baby you know fortune cookies
only come true if you eat the cookie
first eating your fortune cookie while
you still have this much of your entree
left on the plate also is that a glass
plate and are they getting served at the
table episode doesn't know how to Panda
Express correctly family time is time
well spent okay that's not only empty
it's been disproven Beth would be
excellent at fortune cookie sins you
will have sex with your mother in bed
wait no I was just gonna add the
infamous in bed gag to someone's Fortune
I didn't realize this would be a sex
with your mom episode I was set up by
the Rick and Morty writers and you know
it also sure right it's not an ideal
thing to get in a fortune cookie and
certainly shocking but Jerry is speaking
at the same volume as when he talked
about getting the shots from the zoo
earlier and no one in the restaurant
reacted to that over four episodes into
the sixth season and we still haven't
gotten the Sherlock Holmes episode this
scene promises I am very bothered by the
very far from Center buttons on Jerry's
pajamas Jerry Are you seriously asking
if I think you're gonna have sex with
your mom he is man I really hate that
this Cliffhanger of a question is
actually intriguing me this is the who
shot Jr of Rick and Morty incest
Cliffhangers and unfortunately making
cliffhanger's plural was not an accident
on my part sleepy Gary wasn't real
neither are fortune cookies I mean The
Fortunes in the cookies might not be
real but fortune cookies are indeed real
you can hold them you can eat them you
can stick your well yeah then you should
definitely hit that Morty raises his arm
for a high five before his punch line is
delivered and some are proactively preps
for the high five without knowing if the
joke would even be good enough and now
we know that Jerry familiar with tucking
so he either has no pubic hair or is
able to shave very quickly all things I
did not need to know about Jerry also
walking into your parents room at any
time without knocking even if she's
trying to catch her dad doing something
embarrassing this is still a horrible
risk Rick walks this way with towel over
his shoulder then this way with three
rolled towels a second later and here he
comes by with another set of folded
towels you know he's not doing house
chores now all I care about is what
seven moisture absorbing pieces of
fabric could possibly be needed for okay
I'm just as likely to balloon as I am to
become a dolphin things overheard at the
DND table while reviewing the chaos
table calculations somehow make their
way into the script why is this person
holding a tray of food as if they're
going on a lunch break when the stores
closed and currently under attack I'm
gonna take the truck in exchange for not
turning you in I'm gonna sit in the
convenience of the fortune cookie truck
that just happens to be in the back and
now we're being retina scanned maybe
somebody knows the answer to this but I
don't so I'm sitting why Jerry would
need to have his eyes closed for the
retina scan but Rick would not you can't
crack a smile oh yeah you're worried
about doing it with your mom okay fair
enough
it sure is nice for the company to
Showcase torture in the adjacent
conference room you know to be sure that
our infiltrating Duo can see the
positive and negative impacts of the
cookies without having to walk more than
a few feet use the emergency fortunes
you'll have great success in a fight the
cookie designed for an emergency is
fight related what if the emergency had
been a fire if the security guard fought
the fire with water would that have
fulfilled the wish and if the wishes can
be fulfilled by a more vague approach
couldn't Jerry's wish be completed with
a game of poker that ends with Jerry
tossing the table and exclaiming you me
mom hate crawling through a [ __ ] air
vent maybe try going forward through the
air vents that makes it much much easier
why is the creepy alien Handler touching
the wish list with bare skin and also
using this Grabber thing is if it's
important to not touch the paper with
his fingers I'm just trying to make
sense of something simple that I can
understand while the episode derails
into portals and alien poop which I do
not understand fortune cookies are alien
poop ladies and gentlemen I would buy
this on a shirt and I'm sure that is a
sin does the alien want that it's not
exactly what I'd call a sentient species
a man no so let me get this straight
this guy wants to [ __ ] alien the
proper way so he creates extra mom
cookie in hopes that someone will come
and investigate a highly secure evil
Corporation and accidentally their way
to the secret area to discover the
exploitation of an alien creature which
would trigger an empathetic response and
encourage them to free the alien and the
Dirty Man allowing them to [ __ ]
Harmony forever your friends picked me
up in a limousine being so impressed
with the luxury of the car that picks
you up from the airport that you're able
to ignore the multiple semi-automatic
weapons pointed at your back for
someone's trying to be the most
successful businesswoman in the world
this company sure is leaving a lot of
profit on the floor literally come on
and [ __ ] already at this point I'm
pretty sure Rick and Morty is simply
trying to title my sex tape but I'm not
that easy actually yes I am I just used
a dark web account to hack Goldman Sachs
remove trillions of dollars and purchase
everything your company offers
congratulations you're officially the
most successful businesswoman on Earth
see this is why I strongly suggest
defining what success means to you
before you start on a project in this
case for a sudden definition of success
fulfills the cookies prophecy rather
than her version of success totally
avoidable I see that I've romanticized a
wild animal the same way Margaret Howe
did when she jerked off that dolphin in
the 1960s I mean there's no way that
actually happened
oh for the love of why are there
pictures so this guy's guts get sucked
out of his body but Rick's guts aren't
sucked out of his ass man I guess I just
don't understand how much of Rick is
robot or human and how that impacts his
immortality it's a super good thing that
Rick pack the Nano laser printer in his
arm Cannon this morning and thought I
had to build the cookie ammunition
Chambers in the first place what a champ
we should all strive to be more like
Rick
God damn it I think I think God has
indeed damned the show damned it
straight to hell where we TV sends
freaks are prodding it with our dingy
pitchforks and having a blast thank you
God for sending it to us Jerry's mother
is held in a gynecological exam position
by her right ankle alone and her left
leg isn't being sucked backward she
should have a broken pelvis
foreign
to yourself what the hell I'll just eat
some trash you know fortune cookies only
come true if you eat the cookie first
you sure that doesn't sound right you're
gonna be eaten by a big greasy monster
have a nice day why are you dressed like
Morty that got a little goat that tiny
little goat these are two shoe boxes
oops in the Box pain can I just tell you
which box I would put my penis in boys
have a penis girls have a vagina
ship favorites playlist track one I'm
going to do a terrific show today and
I'm going to help people because I'm
good enough